implicit in what you're saying now
is a hopeful message that with platforms
we can
take a step towards uh greater and
greater
popularity of truth but the more cynical
view
is that what the last few years have
revealed
is that there's a lot of money to be
made in
dismantling the even the idea of truth
that nothing is true and ever as a
thought experiment
i've been you know thinking about if
it's possible that our future will have
like the idea of truth is something we
won't even have
do you think it's possible like in the
future
that everything is on the table in terms
of truth and we're just
swimming in this kind of digital economy
where
ideas are just little
toys they're not at all connected to
reality
yeah i think that's definitely possible
i'm not a technological determinist
so i don't think that's inevitable i
don't think it's inevitable that it
doesn't happen
i mean the thing that i've come away
with every time i do these studies and i
emphasize
in my books and elsewhere is that
technology doesn't shape our destiny we
shape our destiny
so just by us having this conversation i
hope
that your audience is going to take it
upon themselves as they design their
products and they think about their used
products as they manage companies
how can they make conscious decisions to
favor truth over fall so it's favor the
better
kinds of societies and not advocate and
say well we just built the tools i think
there was a
a saying that uh that was the german
scientist when they were working on the
uh the missiles
um in late world war ii you know they
said well
our job is to make the missiles go up um
where they come down that's someone
else's department
and you know that's obviously uh uh not
the i think it's obvious that's not the
right attitude that technologists should
have that engineers
should have they should be very
conscious about what the implications
are
and if we think carefully about it we
can avoid the kind of world that you
just described where where truth is all
relative
there are going to be people who benefit
from a world of
where people don't check facts and where
truth is relative and
popularity or or fame or money
is orthogonal to truth but
one of the reasons i suspect that we've
had so much progress over the past
few hundred years is the invention of
the scientific method
which is a really powerful tool or meta
tool for finding truth
and favoring things that are
true versus things that are false if
they don't pass the scientific method
they're less likely to be
true and that has
the societies and the people and the
organizations that embrace that
have done a lot better um than the ones
who haven't and so i'm hoping
that people keep that in mind and
continue to try to embrace not just the
truth but methods that lead to the truth
you